make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so continuing on with our dawn of x
series of videos we're covering
excalibur now remember for those of you
guys who are joining us we're going
through each one of these individually
for the first story arc and then after
that we'll just kind of go from there
right one of the things that i believe
when it comes to
new launches or or new comics is you
should always give it one story arc and
then let that story arc determine
whether or not you enjoy it right you
can't really determine whether or not a
story is going to be good based on like
the first comic right it doesn't really
work that way because things can change
drastically over the course of a single
single line of comics right like
literally the story of superior
spider-man like doctor octopus is just
like a villain who gets the body of
peter parker but it's like it becomes an
amazing story by the time you get to the
end right so you can't really use like a
single issue to judge the whole thing
but uh here's the thing about here's the
thing about excalibur the way this is
being written the way this is
this is being done it's really really
cool but if you don't care
anything about like camelot and like
morgan le faye and things like that
you're not gonna like this story
because it's literally 100 that stuff
but we need to talk about this so the
idea of camelot is that in marvel comics
it largely follows the arthurian mythos
right camelot was a kingdom of king
arthur you had gwynevere you had
lancelot all that kind of cool stuff um
ultimately in marvel superheroes number
17 in 1968 camelot fell
and the result was that it was moved to
other world now other world is a
dimension that exists in marvel comics
it's basically outside the multiverse
right so it kind of exists as part of it
but not necessarily at the same time and
so far that the reason why is because
what you have is the wizard merlin and
merlin
basically created a group called the
captain britain core and the captain
written core
is this organization that's like the
green lantern corps from dc comics but
instead of the green lantern corps
protecting each sector of space the
captain britain corps each each member
protects its own universe now
for the most part doesn't really matter
just because there are such exceedingly
powerful beings in those universes the
captain britain couldn't even begin to
hope to stand a chance against but it
works because you can call in
a bunch of captain britons to face off
against a particular threat but that's
one of the things that's kind of going
on here
morgan lafaye is probably one of the
more powerful beings in marvel comics
when it comes to using magic
shoe is one of the students of merlin uh
she is she was actually considered to be
the replacement for doctor strange after
he lost his ability to become sorcerer
supreme when she decides to rain
hellfire down on you like it's coming
[Laughter]
she's really really really really
powerful but the other thing about this
is
is arthur pendragon king arthur himself
during dan abner's run on hercules which
i think is considered hercules vol 2 in
2016. arthur pendragon was summoned by
hercules and i believe he fought in that
that
small little war that little uh conflict
that was going on there but essentially
since then
leading up until now he's vanished we
didn't really know what was going on
with it now a lot of that was due to the
fact that at the time rover wasn't
really publishing anything on king
arthurs it was just kind of like okay
whatever you know it's out there doing
its thing but within the confines of
this story the
the whole idea is like he's vanished
like we don't really know where he is or
what's going on the other thing that's
going on here is that within the kingdom
of camelot itself what you essentially
have here at least as morgan lafaye
interprets it is kind of like an
invasion of sorts it's this idea that
there are forces within camelot working
against her now
technically she's the steward of camelot
she's basically the one who's
essentially ruling in place of king
arthur and so because of the fact that
she was the one that initially led to
the downfall of camelot as she is more
often than not depicted as a villain it
does kind of make sense that they would
be working against her but we don't
really know who the white witch
is we're not really sure exactly what
all is going on there instead what we
end up doing here
is we actually end up picking up with
with psylocke with betsy braddock
now one of the things that i want to
point out here is this idea of psylocke
basically going back to being a
caucasian woman again the reason why
is is back in ikea x-men 256 chris
claremont had this idea to basically
rework psylocke in her entirety and
basically put her
mind more or less in the body of a
japanese woman named kwon now that's
that's probably explained better in our
video on
psylocke explained so you're welcome to
go check it out the long and short of it
is that for
decades psylocke was basically in the
body of a japanese woman and that was
kind of her identity going forward right
that's how people associated with her
most people who got into the x-men and
like the 90s remember psylocke as that
version
this really ran up until mystery and
madrapore as part of the return of
wolverine and the reason why was because
the return of wolverine and marvel
comics kind of marks this paradigm shift
with regards to the x-men right in so
far is marvel's no longer just kind of
shuffling them to the background and
whatever happens happens instead it was
kind of bringing them back into the
forefront and really leading up to
jonathan hickman's run on the team and
so as a result of that there were a lot
of changes that were made to existing
characters
most of those came by way of jonathan
hickman during house and powers of x
when different x-men were basically
resurrected but during mystery and mad
report
cylo got her body back she got her
original body back and so that's why
right now when you look at her she's
essentially her original caucasian self
the funny thing about this is she
basically ends up going to visit with
apocalypse and this is kind of an
important thing because what this does
is it shows what apocalypse is doing now
and that was really the big question
that i had going on
coming out of house and powers of x is
what's apocalypse doing what's his role
going to be right if he's part of the
mutant council is he biting his time to
basically somehow
take over and and like crush everybody
or test them all or whatever the case is
what's going on with this character and
what this really shows is that
apocalypse is actually
turning over a new leaf the biggest
issue with this and one of the big
things that apocalypse is trying to
figure out at the moment is why it is
that one of their doors from kokoa
cannot access
otherworld this is kind of a cool thing
because what this shows is that
apocalypse is aware of places like
otherworld he's aware of other
dimensions and the multiverse right he's
aware of more that there's more than
just
earth but what this does is this
basically picks up with a holy new
character kind of transitioning away
from kokoa and it picks up with a wholly
new character now this character's name
is marianna stern and in reality she's
part of what's called the coven
was a coven solar blackwood this as far
as i'm aware is wholly new but in
reality it's this
the covenant she's a part of isn't the
real big takeaway here the real big
takeaway here is how
magic works in in marvel comics this is
kind of a big thing here right this is a
huge revelation that goes on here
because while they're
you know running their enchantments and
so on and so forth what they end up
doing is basically
unintentionally invoking uh morgan
lafaye and so far as morgan le faye
realizes somebody
outside of other world basically in the
maine marvel universe is using magic
and ultimately she deems it as somebody
who seems to be kind of intruding on her
on her territory now of course she kind
of jumps into this and basically says
like my entire kingdom's under attack
i'm trying to figure out what's going on
here
even even morgan left doesn't really
know what's happening and so what she
basically does is she tasks the kevin
blackwood she says like you guys need to
go figure out what's going on if you
don't figure out what's going on i'm
cutting magic off to all of you and
that's a really important thing here and
the reason why is because the use of
magic and marvel comics comes in a
couple different forms right you have
magic like the scarlet witch or like
doctor strange which is usually magic
given to them by like other entities and
and beings that are out there right so
doctor strange doesn't really have magic
and so far as it's inherent to him he
uses the abilities of like
of like watum and and you know sidorak
and so on and so forth and scarlet witch
channels the power of catholic but what
you also have in marvel comics are
beings like agatha harkness and agatha
harkness is an actual witch right she'd
you know boil boil toil in trouble you
know using a giant cauldron different
things like that killing rodents and so
on and so forth she uses actual magic
but the magic she uses
is channeled directly from camelot
itself from the magic of merlin
and so the result of this is that in
order for her to be able to continue
using magic and even the coven to be
able to continue using magic morgan le
faye basically has to keep those
channels open which she can close at any
point in time
what it does is kind of offer an
explanation on the other half of magic
and marvel that we always knew was there
but never really got a full in-depth
explanation on in terms of how it worked
or or
how these abilities were channeled and
given to various people this is kind of
a cool thing because what it means is
that morgan le faye does not know who's
attacking her kingdom so we're not
really given all the answers in this
we're just kind of left wondering a
little bit which makes sense because
it's the first issue wouldn't really
make any sense to wrap the whole arc up
in the first issue
what reason would you have to read the
other five but there's other there's
other cool little things that come out
of this for example jamie braddock is
basically resurrected so he's
essentially brought back from the dead
that's one of the things to keep in mind
here guys is
over the years between house of m
running up until the modern era
a lot of x-men have died right like a
lot of mutants out there have been
killed by
one means or another what dawn of x is
designed to do is kind of reset the
x-men back to the status quo to not
necessarily pretend like nothing after
house of impact we know all that stuff
took place but it's designed to kind of
bring the team back to its roots and so
resurrecting and bringing back a lot of
these mutants who have been away for a
long time
is kind of a cool thing to see here
because as we know with jamie braddock
he can manipulate reality right so he's
an exceedingly powerful character to
have on their team
it's very important that he's there but
for the character of apocalypse it's
like you know why in the world aren't
these things being enabled right like
why aren't we able to
to basically you know access this portal
and get into the and get into other
world because there are mutant beings
who reside in them so the question is
how do we access that area and so it's
kind of a cool thing because what you
end up basically getting
it's bessie braddock and captain britain
who essentially teleport to this
location now here's the important thing
to understand
about captain britain for all the
abilities that brian braddock has his
powers are not strictly his own and the
reason why i say that is because when
brian braddock was was presented with a
possibility or at least presented with
the offering of becoming captain britain
by merlin and his daughter roma he was
basically presented with two artifacts
the first one was the amulet of right
and the second one was the sword of
might and the idea behind these two
things
is that depending on what you choose uh
your role and your costume and your
powers to a degree will change but
regardless it's basically an offering to
become a captain britain brian braddock
chose the amulet of right and what the
amulet did is basically as long as he
wore it around his neck
it would allow him to channel the powers
of captain britain it would give him
flight and energy projection and
durability different things like that
the sword of might itself would
basically
allow powers that were almost identical
to the traditional captain written
abilities but in turn uh you would also
have like this you know
insanely powerful artifact in terms of a
weapon now the amulet represented life
and the sword represented death but
it's kind of a cool little thing the
idea behind this though is that brian
braddock channeling the the you know
power of the captain written court while
he's not
all powerful he is a guy that you do
want on your side right he's pretty
capable in terms of his abilities the
issue is that with him traveling
basically to uh other world alongside
betsy braddock what we end up learning
is that what's going on with this device
here at least you know her this is this
kind of invasion that she sees
is essentially the springing up of these
portals by mutants from cocoa right so
this idea that this portal basically
sprung up she doesn't really know how it
works or what's going on with it and so
she ultimately ended up kind of cutting
it off so nobody could get through that
portal and into the realm of other world
which is within her power to do
apocalypse in this guys
don't know this and that's kind of the
question that's being asked here the
issue with this is that morgan lafaye
alongside mordred have always been
enemies of captain britain and so of
course when captain britain shows up
here it's her chance to seize his power
and to basically take it
merlin has been dead for a long time and
so has roma right so it's not like
they're gonna step
in and they're gonna protect captain
britain and all these guys that's not
going to play out that way instead you
have psylocke fending off against
morgan le faye as best she can but she's
no real match here and so as a result of
that what ends up happening is morgan le
faye basically transforms captain
britain into her black knight now this
depiction of the black knight of morgan
le fay is not to be confused with dane
whitman right the wielder of the ebony
blade which is to say the sword that
basically
becomes more and more evil more or less
as time goes on demands blood
and so on and so forth these are two
distinctly different things all this is
designed to do is basically illustrate a
corrupted captain written more or less
you know
a guy that basically works in service of
morgan le faye and can't really do
anything on his own i mean he can do a
degree like he goes as far as to give
the amulet directly to psylocke so that
she can channel his power
and essentially become the new captain
britain but while all that's going on
you end up having apocalypse who gathers
together rogue and trinary and basically
uses rogue's abilities as i mean to kind
of try to tap
into the power of the curcumin gate and
then in turn enter in and bring out
betsy braddock the problem with this and
the issue that you end up facing while
all this is going down
is that ultimately the end result is
achieved this sort of betsy braddock
comes flying out but the curcumin gate
is shattered and what this does is kind
of create like this mental backlash
right and we've seen that happen before
with the character of rogue
if rogue is basically if she's exposed
to too much power too fast it'll put her
into a comatose state and that's exactly
what happens here right she basically
ends up going into a catatonic state
betsy braddock essentially you know it's
kind of left there to face off against
you know the black knight of of uh of
morgan lafaye as well as
uh morgan le faye herself which
ultimately she ends up using the amulet
to essentially make her escape as best
she can
becoming the new captain britain in the
process but for the character of rogue
this is what i want to talk about here
for a second for the character of rogue
her being left in a comatose state here
i want to kind of jump back to what's
called the hecaton right this is kind of
a big thing the heck of tomb was this
massive bomb this kind of weapon that
was created by the shia
empire that was designed for the purpose
of inflicting
massive loss of life right but the idea
was that when rogue touched it she ended
up absorbing
all these minds right just like billions
and billions of minds all at the same
time and the result of that is that it
was exceedingly overwhelming to her and
shut her down and put her
put her in a comatose state where she
laid until after the events of masai
complex but that's kind of the big thing
here is that what this does
is one it knocks out rogue which is one
of the more powerful characters of the
x-men but it also gives us potential
into what it is that she saw
in the moments that this this uh this
gateway basically shattered betsy
braddock comes out as the new captain
britain which is cool but the biggest
takeaway from all this this is the
biggest thing to kind of keep in mind
here is that what you end up getting is
marianna stern who basically kills her
coven right like kills the
the the solar blackwood coven and then
leaves and joins the clan of cabba the
height you know she becomes a high
priestess for the clan of cabot and this
is important because the clan of habit
has been shown
as both allies of apocalypse as well as
enemies of apocalypse what this looks
like is the version of clanacaba that
basically worships apocalypse and so
what it looks like is going on here is
apocalypse has
engineered all of this stuff for what
reason we don't know but apocalypse
seems to have engineered all of this
set all these things in motion so he can
make his move somewhere along the line
and then implement whatever plan it is
that he wants to
implement but based on this first issue
it looks like apocalypse is doing
business as usual
he's being a bad guy but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you